un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
sí
un gusto recibirlos en estos primeros
días del año 2021 reciban nuestros
deseos porque este año 2021 sea bello y
enriquecedor y hoy en carrusel de las
artes nos invitamos a un viaje de
sabores y de costumbres culinarias
recuperados y recopilados en un libro
que se llama la vuelta al mundo en 80
sabores sabores y olores que también han
inspirado a la canción francesa lo
veremos más adelante en nuestra crónica
musical con natale olivares
[Música]
y bueno en este primer carrusel de las
artes del año los vamos a invitar a un
viaje por el mundo dos autores se han
inspirado en la obra de julio verne para
proponernos una vuelta al mundo en 80
días' sino en 80 sabores ellos han
pasado 30 años viajando por el mundo y
recopilando y saboreando estas recetas
que les presentan en este libro que se
llama en francés lotus limón oncca trova
sábado recibimos entonces a piaf viña mi
francés y coautor de este libro gracias
por estar con nosotros hoy gracias por
invitarme y el otro autor de este libro
es el escritor cubano william navarrete
muchísimas gracias william por estar
aquí con nosotros y bueno ahora vamos a
empezar con copiar porque justamente
este libro que es una recopilación de
anécdotas que ustedes han podido vivir
durante 30 años de viajes
este libro comienza con su historia
personal pierre con esa abuela italiano
usted es nacido aquí en francia pero
descendiente de italianos y es esa
abuela italiana a quien quizás le picó
la curiosidad
descubrir la cocina y descubrir sabores
exactamente mi abuela tenía un
restaurante cerca de niza 5 kilómetros
en pueblo que se llama vil facciones que
era antes un pueblo de pescadores y es
un sitio espectacular y todavía sigue es
muy bonito y así el niño yo pasaba mis
vacaciones de verano con ella y yo la
veía cocinando y así empecé a mirar pero
ella era no podía tocar nada había que
mirar nada más y entonces ya empezó a
ella a cocinar y porque ella con sus
hermanas vinieron de editar ya de hombre
ya emigraron en los años 20 huyendo del
fascismo de mussolini y entonces aportó
sus recetas sus costumbres y entonces en
el restaurante hacia año que la hazaña
canelón y pasta de todo hasta la torta
de acerca que yo mencioné en el libro y
que se hace es una especialidad inicio
se hace salar
o dulce y la gente venía de misa hasta
bill foursomes para comprar esos
productos justamente esta es la primera
receta esta torta de acelgas que yo no
sabía que podía ser respectivamente
dulce o salado y se encuentra
especialmente en liza en todas las
panaderías es que fuera de niza de
verdad que no se encuentra mucho
encontramos volvimos a exportar la
receta original en un pueblo que se
llama actual clubes que le hacía como la
hacía mi abuela
la receta realmente final y ahora bien
william navarrete este libro recopila
recetas 80 recetas pero quizás las
recetas son el pretexto para ustedes
también hablar de sus anécdotas de la
historia de los lugares donde han estado
o de los productos que han probado
exactamente yo no recuerdo haber hecho
nunca un viaje en el que no esté
presente casi que como columna vertebral
del viaje porque además soy bastante
goloso
los golosos suelen decir que son gourmet
para no decir que son guzmán pero yo soy
golosos y lo reconozco demás de modo que
para cada sitio en que visito es
esencial y es vital ir hacia lo que yo
considero que es la estructura de la
sociedad que es la cocina en tanque que
es como tal de hecho siempre se ha dicho
que cuando una sociedad periclita cuando
la sociedad ya está en la decadencia
total y absoluta lo último que se pierde
es la cocina y esto lo hemos podido ver
en algunos países entre ellos yo creo
que el mío en el que se ha perdido
muchísimo de la cocina tradicional
porque justamente ha habido una
descomposición de todo tipo entonces por
eso quizás mi obsesión de ir siempre a
la búsqueda de
de los platos tradicionales en cada
sitio que visitó y de la de lo que sería
la parte auténtica no la que se le
presenta al turista y tal sino la cocina
auténtica realmente local hecha por por
la incluso por las personas más humildes
si justamente ustedes hablas de cocina
tradicional de esos productos auténticos
viajas en este libro no hay grandes
restaurantes en la tradición francesa de
restaurantes de grandes estrellas aquí
ustedes siempre fueron a pequeñas
tabernas a pequeños lugares donde sabían
que podía haber un platillo que ustedes
querían probar exactamente a mí me
gustaba viajar fuera de los dos fuera de
los circuitos turísticos y yo recuerdo
con mi trabajo porque yo trabajé por
compañías aéreas en por ejemplo en
tahití yo andaba en los transportes
de la gente de la isla y yo paraba
porque ahí sabía como camiones donde
ellos hacía la comida y yo bajaba del
transporte yo paraba para comer la
comida auténtica
por ejemplo el pescado crudo a la
tradicional el chau men que es una
comida que viene de china cosas así y
ahora hay muchos momentos
- en este libro uno de ellos william es
un banquete en arabia saudita donde
usted nos cuenta como ellos comen sin
platos y solo con la mano derecha porque
la izquierda no se usa los zurdos como
yo estamos mal en arabia sana como comer
con la mano además y sin usar la mano a
la mano como se llama la mano izquierda
si en realidad es un país muy particular
porque todo el mundo sabe que arabia
saudita no es un país turístico entonces
yo tuve la oportunidad de ir por
relaciones personales con una amiga
y mi terror porque además allí en
realidad cuando estás invitado
oficialmente los hombres comen de un
lado las mujeres del otro
y mis aliados allí eran mujeres de modo
que me encontró de pronto una comida
invitado a un alto nivel por hombres y
en el medio de la mesa un carnero una
cordero enorme degollado y acostado es
que arranchado con los ojos mirándome
porque la cara la pusieron de frente a
mí y aparentemente el honor del invitado
de honor es cómo podemos comenzar
comiéndose los ojos del cordero y la
cabeza y yo me quedé horrorizado cuando
me dijeron aquello por supuesto hay que
leer el cuento para saber cómo termina
la historia pero es ciertamente hay
países y muchos en los que las
costumbres difieren mucho de las
nuestras y esa es la parte del libro
siempre en la que
uno tiene hay cierto temor y ciertas
obras que sucedan cosas que no están
previstas y hay algunos ejemplos también
de platillos que pueden ser muy
tradicionales de un lugar y que ustedes
han encontrado de forma increíble en
otros por ejemplo es el caso del cuásar
que nos habla piel
es algo típicamente francés que ustedes
degustaron encontraron en vietnam vio y
lo contamos en el libro en dallas que la
ciudad de dallas está al norte de salgo
encontré los corazón con el sabor y la
textura de mi infancia y eso debido a la
presencia de los franceses en vietnam y
eso se ha perdido aquí en france es que
han cambiado la receta creo que ponen
muchos broadway margarinas no sé pero
era realmente otra formación diferente
antes no lo natural y también
encontramos comida mejor paella en casa
de unos exiliados del franquismo en
parís la mejor paella que no había
encontrado en en españa
en las afueras de parís y otro ejemplo
el congrí cubano el congrí cubano y más
todavía por ejemplo en platos de cuba
que yo no conocía
que había oído mencionar pero como eran
casi piezas arqueológicas del pasado y
por supuesto visitando miami donde hay
tantos cubanos exiliados donde hay
mejores condiciones alimenticias y tal
bueno pues allí de pronto descubrir
boliche que es una que tiene una forma
de preparar la carne de res que es
maravillosa porque es como una carne
mechada un poco como en venezuela y sea
adentro se le introduce como una especie
de mecha con un preparado especial y tal
de embutidos y muchísimos platos más que
expresar y el que yo he ignorado
completamente que gracias a que ya se
han podido conservar fuera de cuba
todavía existen y bueno vamos a hacer un
paréntesis en nuestra conversación
porque la cocina en los productos
culinarios también han nutrido a la
canción francesa y es de lo que nos
habla natale olivares en esta crónica
musical
[Música]
la música siempre ha sido un objeto de
inspiración para los músicos e incluso
ha servido para escribir textos con
connotación sexual como por ejemplo la
famosa canción de shanghang o les -usted
alanís o más recientemente la habana
definitiva
[Música]
sí
quien no quiere trabajar solo quiere que
lo dejemos en paz comiendo esa fruta
sólo en la playa y otra canción con
muchas metáforas sensuales es la canción
la fam choco la de olivia gris
[Música]
bueno
la falso cola habla de esas grandes
transformaciones del cuerpo durante el
período de la adolescencia y el gran y
famosísimo en madrid quiso hablar de ese
complejo de ser francés en relación a la
cultura de eeuu
eso se llama el complejo del corn flakes
blue complex you con flex
flex
m debería quedarse tranquilo y no tener
complejos simplemente porque creció en
la capital de la gastronomía
parís según lo reivindica esta famosa
película ratatouille y esa canción
luisfe estaba cantada por camila
no
sí
[Música]
gracias natale olivares por esta crónica
musical y regresamos con nuestros
invitados aquí en el estudio de carrusel
de las artes piaf biniamín y william
navarrete autores de este tour del mundo
aunque acaban saber la vuelta al mundo
en 80 sabores viaja en este libro
también están algunas recetas que no son
demasiado apetitosas me acuerdo de una
anécdota en malawi como una torta hecha
aunque yq a base de moscas así mismo yo
de verdad que no es apetitosa para
nosotros pero quizás para ellos sí pero
ellos lo hacen esa receta porque en
aquella época y creo que tú la vida de
sos y que no tenían carne y proteínas y
entonces ellos recogen moscas y te hace
una le hace una torta de
y lo puse por razón de la lec 2 tica y
bueno ya no nos queda muy poco tiempo le
voy a hacer la última pregunta de
william yo quisiera para resumir que nos
dijera cuál es la receta que usted ha
probado más extraordinaria en estos
viajes que ha hecho por el mundo no es
difícil porque todos me gustan casi
exacto el uso de moscas por supuesto
pero por ejemplo ya mí me encanta el
servicio peruano bien hecho cuando está
bien hecho cuando lo comes en perú como
debe ser la bandeja paisa que nos
recuerda tanto al pabellón venezolano o
la completa cubana pero es que para los
colombianos realmente verdaderamente
completa porque les ponen de todo y le
ponen más que lo que le ponemos nosotros
y una bandeja paisa un pueblo como
jardín en medellín en la provincia de
antioquia es una maravilla eso es algo
inolvidable bueno yo creo que le abrimos
el apetito a las personas que nos vieron
y que nos escucharon muchísimas gracias
a piaf vino a mí y william navarrete
autores de esta vuelta al mundo en 80
sabores a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía y nos vemos la próxima semana
cuídense mucho
dudas
[Música]